okay yes today is a little bit abnormal
except it's not is it
this is just another Tuesday yeah mythic
quests is a testament to the madness
that is a video game development company
our characters are people from all
different cultures all different walks
of life I think that's why it's so funny
this show comes from the people that
makes it's always sunny all right all
right all right do I do that yeah that
sort of gives the flavor for a lot of
comedy you know I bet creative it's kind
of my back no it's not your bag is being
a soy boy beta Cup that's it what is
that
I'll explain it to you later it was that
good thing the show does a really good
job of portraying the way the ball
bounce off of and disagree with and love
and hate each other
blue jeans I am don't you hate Brad hate
him oh yeah I do hate him yeah I feel
nothing for him he's a sociopath
it's so smart and powerful and funny but
quite right these watermelons don't
explode like real heads but also like
full-blown crazy I can get you real
heads not human Joe please don't get him
heads that's commitment
kind of fun to take a peek behind the
curtain of a creative group I think it's
a really cool thing to explore you must
be so excited
hi my puke hot take games bring us
together on a global level in a way that
very few other things do this could be
the biggest event in the history of
mythic quest what is happening my god I
think it's brilliant
[Music]
you